the Justice Department is cracking down
on so-called sanctuary cities DOJ
announced this week it will withhold
grant money from these cities unless
they give federal immigration
authorities access to jails the
Department wants to know in advance when
undocumented immigrants will be released
and at least one city is fighting back
on this the Denver City Council is
reportedly considering a proposal to
keep federal officials in the dark Mary
Peterson looks at both sides of this
confrontation this was an arrest by ice
agents at the front door of Denver's
courthouse the illegal immigrant with a
felony conviction in his background was
wrestled into custody he has since been
deported but showdowns like these say
Denver officials are a risk to public
safety
Denver's Mayor Michael Hancock asked ice
to stop making arrests of the city
courthouse we want people to trust the
judicial system and we need them to show
up like schools churches and hospitals
he wants the courthouse designated as a
sensitive location which would prevent
agents from arresting immigrants there
ice refused his request Hancock says
undocumented immigrants without any
criminal history are now avoiding the
courthouse at least nine cases of
domestic violence have been dropped when
victims told authorities they were
afraid to come to the courthouse for
fear of being arrested by ice when
witnesses and victims of crying are not
showing up to you know testify now we
cannot pursue the individuals who have
perpetrated a crime now how does that
make us more safe the City and County of
Denver will not cooperate with a
criminal alien program Philip Miller
oversees deportation agents for ice by
not turning over criminal aliens in a
safe secure environment they're actually
putting my officers and the community at
risk
he says Denver isn't cooperating with
ice because Denver is not alerting the
agency when it has a violator in custody
you guys from ice yes sir so ice agents
check public records for court
appearance and as agents must go to the
courthouse or else to homes or
workplaces at much higher risk to
themselves and
the community they are eaten up cut up
and fight scuffles and you feel like
these things are basically avoidable
absolutely avoidable Denver has gone a
step further starting a program aimed at
protecting undocumented immigrants with
lesser violations those with minor
traffic offenses are now allowed to send
in their plea by mail so they can avoid
going to the courthouse that's important
says this man who says he was detained
and was at risk of deportation after a
minor traffic stop it made me feel like
my life just came crashing down he asked
us not to use his name he says in his
community frightened people now go out
only when necessary like getting to work
a lot of commuters feel like they need
to be in hiding otherwise that just
creates a target in their back you feel
hunted yes but says ice they are only
doing their best to uphold the law it's
not hunting it's doing our job for CBS
this morning Barry Petersen in Denver